lisa good morning how are we doing um so
my family um and my in-laws have
been homeschooling since with each other
we've partnered up since march now so
since this pandemic started and i just
want to know how
we can create healthy boundaries and
because recently the the relationship
has changed
a bit and we're coming up into some
challenges that might change the
arrangement we have
talk to me through those talk about
those
so um this is my sister-in-law um
so my husband's sister we've been in a
close relationship we've been close for
a while
um she's married and recently they
um had one of their episodes um fights
uh that caused us to kind of lose that
trust in sending our kids over there for
school
did they have the fight when your kids
were there no
no no we heard about they told us they
told us what happened
and the details and everything and we're
just not comfortable
with everybody being at home working
from home and whatnot
to send our kids over there for her to
teach them there
um so what happened in that fight that
made you lose trust in someone that you
love and care for um they've had similar
fights in the past and this was kind of
the last straw
and there was you know door slamming
uh glass breaking it caught if
i felt like it kind of got violent to
the point where i just
i i don't i've heard too many
of those stories coming from them okay
um
yeah so now you feel like your kids
aren't safe there
correct okay and so how can i help what
are you thinking about doing
well um we recently um we
we changed up the arrangement to where
you know
we expressed our concerns and said um
let's just have school here four days a
week now rather than sending them over
their
uh two days out of the week so you you
are now taking all the teaching on
no she um my sister-in-law comes over to
teach on the days that she was supposed
to teach at her house
but she's um expressing that
it's hard to face us because we're
disappointed and
and we uh don't trust them anymore and
that's what the emotions that she's
having to face
being in a home along with people who no
longer
trust her well yeah so it feels
so let me see if i can get this right um
because i'm almost
in a in a rare turn of events golly man
on this show i have recommended someone
play video games and now i'm siding with
the person you're calling about
so she had a fight with her husband
and they were throwing glasses at each
other and yelling each other and acting
like
five-year-olds right to the point that
you said i don't want my kids over there
anymore
i don't trust her i don't trust her
husband i don't trust that environment
and so but you wanted to still have her
teaching your kids
and so her quote unquote punishment was
she's got to come teach your kids at
your house now
right and and we also recently
hired someone to come teach on her days
so that she doesn't have to teach at our
house anymore
and she's not happy about that or ah
okay so
she said i don't like being because the
way you drew that up
is very much like you're her mom and now
she's grounded
too yeah to your your line of sight
right
and she's an adult she's allowed to yell
and be an idiot with her husband all she
wants
and you're an adult and you're good for
you said i don't want my kids in that
crap right i don't want my kids around
that environment so
that's awesome but then you you punished
her
then she decided she'd like to
punishment so she's back to being a
grown up so she's off
and you hired a tutor essentially to
teach your kids in your home is that
right
right okay and so she doesn't like that
does she
does she want things to go back to the
way they were
yeah she does she wants us to send our
kids over to at her house
and you know for for consistency and
normalcy again and i'm
me and my husband are just not
comfortable with that yeah she didn't
get a vote
i mean if she set up an environment
where you don't feel your kids are safe
then
tough luck you know what i mean and i
know that's hard
and i'm proud of you for drawing a
boundary um
boundaries often come with
you know challenging challenging
derivatives right the
your relationship's never going to be
the same but
i think the the the the fracture in the
relationship started when she had yet
another temper tantrum with her husband
right right so when you tell her
hey i hired a teacher we don't need you
anymore you take care of your kids i'll
take care of mine
how'd that conversation go well it's
more so
you know we still want the kids to be
together but
instead of her teaching it's on those
two days that she's responsible for
it's the tutor that teaches to
you know we wanted her to kind of focus
on herself and maybe that's overstepping
boundaries but
it's um you know she did express that
you know it's
it's hard for her to come here having to
deal with that and it's overwhelming
and you know we wanted to give her some
space and some time to to process all of
it
so the tutor is essentially to take over
her
um be flexible enough to where if she
needs it she could
uh take those two days off and then you
know
if my husband needs it he can take those
two days off because he's also teaching
the kids as well
oh well now i'm back to your side then
you guys are being overly generous here
so five minutes ago when i said i wasn't
on your side
i'm an idiot i i'm super on your side um
it sounds like what y'all have done
sorry sorry no it sounds like you guys
are being overly generous
by saying hey we're going to teach your
kids too
we're going to pay for a tutor you take
the time that you need
and it sounds like she's having a pity
party
and she's embarrassed that she
set up a home environment that you don't
want your kids there anymore
so the grown-up thing for her to do is
to come say i'm sorry i'm going to work
on myself and i'm going to work on
getting better
that's not going to happen right and
the childish thing if she continues the
childish behavior is she's going to put
make you feel uncomfortable for drawing
boundaries in your own home
and i'm just gonna i want to empower you
don't
right if you've got the money and the
ability to pay for a tutor
then that's going to be better for
everybody her kids are welcome that's
super generous of you and that even
gives your husband
a break when he needs it good for you
yeah honestly i wouldn't lose sleep over
it
if she wants to come back and circle up
and connect the friendship great
and you don't have to rub her nose in it
doesn't sound like you are right
if y'all still be friends when y'all can
get together for dinner so be it
but if she suddenly feels uncomfortable
i get her feeling uncomfortable but it's
her own choosing
if she doesn't just i don't feel
comfortable i feel
sad well that's her deal all right
and i i think you're right you can't
make her go work on herself
i would even suggest offering quote
unquote space for her to go work on
herself is a little bit presumptuous
right she's going to be who she's going
to be but i do think it's
noble that you have set up a scenario
where a you drew boundaries
b you're going to continue the the
the agreement you guys had and so you're
helping educate her kids
and you're giving her some time off for
herself um that's noble good for you
hopefully she will circle back
hopefully she will come and say hey i'm
really sorry
i screwed up here and me and my husband
going to work on this
i don't think that's going to happen
unfortunately but
it'd be cool if it did and until then
just love her
just take the responsibilities and
continue to draw your boundaries for you
and your family
high five to you that's awesome and good
for you guys for being
in a financial position where you could
even do that